I was in what they call a follow-up car
which is a car immediately behind the
presidential guard but they're only
about five feet between the two cars and
this was when you heard assault we were
traveling down Main Street large crowds
and Dallas friendly enthusiastic again
we had to turn make a right-hand turn at
the end of main and then a left on a
street called Elm Street that put us
right in front of a building called the
Texas School Book Depository and I was
on the car immediately behind the
presidential car I was on the left hand
side on the running board I was scanning
to my left and ahead where there was an
overpass and all of a sudden I heard
this explosive noise over my right
shoulder and so I immediately looked
toward that noise but I only got as far
as the back of the president's car
because I saw him react to something so
I'm grabbing his throat like this and
then he went down to his left and I knew
something is wrong so I jumped off the
car I ran as fast as I could to get up
on top of the back of the president's
car to form a shield there or a barrier
with my body so that no further damage
could be done so you wanted to take the
bullet if there was going to be any more
gunfire yes that was my job
and so just before I got to the car
there was a third shot that rang out the
first shot hit the president just below
the neck line to the right of the spinal
column and came out through the throat
didn't hit anything hard just soft
material so was survivable but the third
shot that hit him he only hit got hit
twice but it was the third shot that hit
him in the back of the head here but it
exploded out here and it created a
situation where the brain matter blood
bone fragments all came out of the womb
it was quite destructive
and this was what you saw when he when
he came to the car I not only saw it but
I felt it because the blood came all
over me and brain matter and over mrs.
Kennedy and the trunk
I was up
headquarters about 30 of us have been
recruited to be trained as decoding
assistant we just got to the army
headquarter which was 1.8 kilometer from
hypocenter about 1 mile I was on the
second floor of the wooden building I
saw the bluish white flash in the window
and then my body was thrown up in the
air I do remember the sensation of
floating in the air because all the
buildings were flattened by the blast
and obviously the building I was in was
falling and my body was together falling
so you can know you can only from from
the detonation itself what you remember
is the flash and yourself in the air
that's right not no sound well people in
the distance heard that roaring sound
but I didn't I was right in it and some
time later I found myself in the total
darkness and silence and I knew what was
happening to me I was faced with death I
tried to move my body but I couldn't
then I started hearing whispering voices
of the girls around me mother helped me
god help me I remember those voices
belonging to certain people they're
still ringing in my ears from time to
time all of a sudden from behind the
somebody took my left shoulder and with
the male voice said don't give up keep
keep moving keep kicking keep pushing
I'm trying to free you and he helped me
and he also suggested that I should cry
to the direction where the sunray was
coming through so I crawled up in the
total darkness I began to see some
moving object approaching me for a while
I couldn't say what those black things
was but then I could tell they were
injured human beings they didn't look
like human beings I'll tell you their
hair was standing up like why are the
wire standing up and they were covered
with blood and skins were scorched
blackened and skin and flesh were
hanging from their bones and part of the
bodies are missing and some people I
know it this is gross for carrying their
eyeballs in the eye in the hands and
they were slowly shuffling from the
center part of the city but they
collapse onto the ground when they
collapse their stomach burst open with
the intestine stretching out this kind
of situation I witnessed and that summer
7 classmates and I we were arrested
Chinese the public library that was a
real experience they know we do we saved
will a brick and enough to movie
theaters and we began the process and
that process led us to with the end up
we want to wash it him and dr. King give
the speech I have a dream speech and
most of us was I had the honour haven't
been jailed you know became free of
jails and death at that time and what
most people don't realize is the context
of that speech the day he gave that
speech from Texas across the Florida up
to Maryland we can use a single public
toilet in an estate Capitol they give
their speech we couldn't buy screaming
holiday at Howard Johnson
we couldn't buy couldn't remember
something at the end I mine was
counterfeited black and Latino so just
sit behind nots appeal deficit of
American military bases we lived under
the degradation of apartheid so it was I
don't have to Google as it I was I was
living it if he can now go back to to
the 9th of October last year you were on
the school bus what can you remember
from that that happened what happened
well I don't remember that incident and
people say you are lucky what what's the
last thing you remember I was going back
home from school and on that day was my
Pakistan studies paper we were having
exams that we and I was really worried
on that day it was a sad day because I
usually try to get first position in my
class and to defeat all my friends in
the class and be on the top and I was
really worried about my exam paper so
when I was happier on that they're quite
happy because my paper went very well
undertake and oh we were going back home
and I could see the life was just like
normal seeing those people on the
roadside and usually we have a lot of
men on the roadside no women at all and
if you see a woman she would be wearing
a burka and I thought that I said in
that school bus I was going back home
but I didn't know that the journey was
never going to end and I also didn't
know that I'm never going to go back to
my home and the journey finished and I
woke up in a hospital in Birmingham
there was there was a man coming into
the bus right yes and he was asking for
you
so there were two men we will call them
boys because they were in their twenties
they are quite young and my friend told
me the story and some other witnesses as
well one of the boy he stopped the
school when and he was talking to a
driver
my sister is behind and I want to I want
to meet the principal of the school
making excuses just to keep him busy for
a for a while in the other boy he came
at the back of the bus
and he asked who is Malala all the girls
sitting in their school bus this you
can't remember Yuto and my school friend
they all looked at me some of them
didn't but some of them did and they
could not even even imagine what was
happening at that time because you are
living a happy life and you're thinking
about your exam and your homework get
everything and then suddenly things
change so when he asked who is Malala I
could not answer him because he didn't
give me time and when he recognized me
because I was not wearing as I was not
covering my face all the girls were
covering their faces but my face he
could see so that's why he shot me in
the bullet hit me right here on the left
side of my forehead and it just went
down through my neck and into the left
shoulder and when I fell down I felt in
the lap of my best friend Moni ba and
when he were told me that when that boy
asked who is Malala you didn't say
anything neither did you cry nor did you
scream she said you just only force my
hand and you just you're like squeezing
it and then you just in the next few
second you just fell in my lap and then
you my ear was bleeding and especially
my yeah and this part was bleeding and
the other two bullets hit my other
friend school friends Kainat and Shazia
and then suddenly those boys ran away
well the war robbed the call of my
family you know it's robbed the soul in
in my village the first time I witnessed
war I thought the world was ending
because I used to hear my mother telling
me the world is going to end someday and
so and seeing people running different
direction you know you see animals even
confused big bombs dropping ground
shaking like this so much confusion and
I got used to seeing people die I still
haven't had the scars of the war
the first time it happened even might
live got burning so a bike fell on me
and I was on fire so the war reached the
COFF my family so my auntie's died
during the war including my mom all my
uncle's later when I get to hear more
stories were claimed by the war and I
think festered and we keep running from
one place to another and then we had to
walk to Ethiopia you had to walked with
you but that's a that's a very long walk
what's the longest month a lot of kids
died on the way some died of starvation
crossing the rivers they were beaten by
hippopotamus
you know hippopotamus don't eat but they
are very territorial so when you cross
the river they able to smash somebody
into 2 and crocodiles are eating them
some Madonna or swim get drowned
okoma have allotted a menu Anu didn't
the Islamic allocator at foremost the
tangka say but they are not walking them
to come Maidan mood for audiences to
allow our streets very first mini Afra
de rigueur arugula starkest Roca station
some brie and arrows in rooked some
trigger
y'know crucial midi attentive Oda more
go tell don't congregate murders nay the
Hara bhara fabric another whisker
Beatrice area trust under in risk may
and bottom so stored are some service
devote an obese a memorable that put on
so no comet piccata more
did we get mystery Oh Lester damina born
sermon more vivid Verratti some months
neva trifa send you this Coker May last
bill don't can go but difficuity button
to tree doing this Kapooka phonetically
from that now don't come from
so what the ghost grown honest witness
so the first and then to scan some
delimited are they are you sitting
senator lot or dr. Mengele yeah some
over and all they all rushed among can
say yeah
I know that you were in back in 72 you
were in Hanoi when the bombs fell really
hard can you take us back there for a
moment
well when I went it was as a peace group
to meet with a peace group in Hanoi
where they were no North Vietnamese
Communist Party but wanted to talk you
know just to talk and we went over there
was a minister and the Maoist kid is a
little you know a left-wing ex-military
and four-star general with us and we got
there and all I can remember is the
beginning there had not been any bombing
there for half a year so nobody was
expecting the sound of this siren went
off at our second night second big
dinner you know welcoming us and the
siren went off and I'm thinking over
they must have these exercises all the
time then we heard boom boom in the
distance and you know for us we didn't
know what was happening really the
Vietnamese did but they were stunned but
they got us down in bomb shelter and I
remember in the bomb shelter that's
where I understood about my own
mortality I mean I kind of was so
frightened and a lot of times I'm not
frightened they do this stuff and if
they come you get very calm but you
can't be calming that atheist agnostic
everybody saying dear God please don't
let that bomb land on me no then
afterward you feel guilty because it
fell on somebody else I mean it's not a
win-win situation it was it was pretty
terrible I had a moment when I decided
this passage this is not going to run to
the bomb shelter and so the next time
the siren went off I was walking very
slowly there was explosion really really
near and everybody started running and I
ran so fast
I just lost all my brilliant self image
I had I just blood trampled people
trying to get to the bomb shelter this
this story is also famous for what then
happened when you didn't have any food I
mean you had to take extreme measures
yes when did you decide to do that it's
I think our history our story is very
interesting from that point of view for
us it was only the the only thing we
could do and it's so strange to try and
think I would do it I wouldn't do it
you don't look in at a TV show sitting
on an archer ravine a newspaper reading
a book it's completely different over
there
you change you change into the best of
yourself or depending on the point of
view you descend to the worst of
yourself as a human being but the
pressures are completely and I haven't
had any pressures or any problems in the
last 38 years nothing that can compare
to that after 10 days we heard on a
small transistor radio that the search
had been abandoned we were left at 5,000
meters no clothes no food no water no
rescue what do you do you change you're
another person you turn yourself into a
survival machine that is the decision to
to eat human flesh
was it a source of conflict in the group
or no conflict did all of you eat or
no conflict because if there's a fire in
this studio here we run to the door you
wouldn't run toward there is a wall over
there on a limit situation like that all
the brain goes to a different wavelength
and all the information that you have
your loss you are abandoned to die
you're going to die freezing looking at
the eyes of your friends sitting down
here you change you're a different human
being and all the thoughts fall into a
funnel and one comes out we have to
survive we have to eat the only things
to eat are the dead bodies of her
friends and it's so easy
once you're there
it was harder to fight to get water
there's no water at 5,000 meters there
was there was an avalanche as well
wasn't there yeah the mountains are are
a very strong opponent but there there
are true what they are there are
mountains you know men do not belong
there and two and a half weeks after the
plane crashed there was a huge avalanche
because it snows snow skids on top of
the mountains then falls by gravity and
we were right under the our lights and
it's buried 27 of us and it killed eight
and then you were 16 left yeah then and
three four more died and then I I had to
get out of there I walked out with a
friend
I say walked out we trekked 70
kilometers 10 days and a half we cross
the hole and this runs and so on on foot
with Street shoes with Street shoes and
I mean experts say that this is almost
humanly impossible to cross the Andes
Mountains like that yeah why do you
think you made it because I wanted to
see my father I knew that he was back at
home having lost his wife his daughter
his son and we were a normal family but
I knew he couldn't sleep he couldn't
work he couldn't think and I was alive
and the love for my father gave me
strength to go over those mountains
you